[Musique]
ban
est ce que jean michel mr saurait de
près ou de loin
quelqu'un qui pourrait intéresser il est
très gentil mais ça s'est posé la
question à louvain la poser à payrac du
tout dans une autre vie mais non voilà
comment ce qui est bien c'est ce qu'on
appelle dans le foot 1 2 0 donc bref
voilà a commencé une boum à cette boum
parra quart d'heure américain nord on va
mettre à flot et chaque fille va pouvoir
inviter la personne de son choix
[Applaudissements]
et comoli les mousses ont changé ok bah
écoute c'est mon dossier ont balancé
[Musique]
faites vous plaisir
oubliez les caméras oubliez votre vie
ailleurs et là bas si il n'y a qu'une
seule debout qui compte c'est la boule à
facettes lourd secret la ligue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]